okay
so what we're going to do in talking
about social preferences is
the following we're going to start
discussing um what are social
preferences you're going to just talk
about like
what do you think social preferences are
and how do we think about them how do we
measure them this is partially what we
did already
in class last week which gives you some
sense of some ways of measuring them
there are
other ways of doing that we're going to
discuss that we're going to also discuss
a bit kind of like the measurements that
we did in class that seems sort of
pretty contrived in various ways
are they actually predictive in some
ways of real-world behavior that we care
about
then we're going to ask the question
well it seems like from measuring social
preferences as we did in class but also
in some experiments that we see
it looks like people are actually quite
nice to each other but we're going to
ask the question are people just
generally lies to each other do they
actually care about others or is it just
like in some ways perhaps social image
or other issues about like they want to
look nice or they want to feel good by
being nice to others who look like
um they're nice to others as opposed to
generally caring about the well-being
of others and so that we're going to
talk through some experiments and some
evidence that lets us disentangle
between those kinds of
hypotheses are people generally lice or
are they sort of just trying to look
nice in various ways
and then we're going to talk about a bit
about evidence uh towards the end this
is a paper by gautam rao and others
which is the question about are social
preferences malleable and can
policies change pro-sociality that is to
say you know can we do certain things
can we mix people in certain ways can be
like
this would be true uh you know how
roommates are chosen
can we sort of um and the specific paper
we're going to talk about is from india
where like
poor students are mixed with rich
students and does that affect how nice
people are
the rich students in this case towards
poor students but also towards other
people in general
so are there some policies that we can
perhaps implement that help
uh people being a society as a whole
being more pro-social and people being
nicer to each other or doing things that
are good for uh
the greater good if you want overall um
as before we're going to look at two
types of evidence we're going to look at
lab experiments and field evidence
lab experiments for the types of
experiments that you saw
so far and field evidence are sort of um
uh
the type of experiments where like we
look at students being mixed rich and
poor students what happens then to
people's social preferences when you do
that
okay so now um let's sort of back up a
little bit and sort of
review very quickly what we did um um
last week i showed you sort of an action
three games to measure social
preferences these are sort of not
randomly selected games these are those
the most prevalent the most commonly
used games in
in uh behavioral experimental economics
which is the dictator game ultimatum
game and the trust game
you can read descriptions and
discussions of these games and the
background readings which is camera and
fair um 2004.
now uh what are these games i'm going to
like briefly sort of review them
right now and then i'm going to go to
them evidence and go back to like
evidence that actually uses these games
so one of the games just to recap
there's a dictator game which is very
simple
where the dictator gets some money
allocated to him or her
and there's another person who is a
recipient and a dictator just gets to
choose how much money does he or she
wants to give to this other person
that's it
you can think of this as some raw
concern for others essentially to say
but you don't often when you don't know
anything about this other person often
these gains are anonymous here's an
anonymous person whom you could give
some money
often it's another student it could be
like a poor person in kenya or elsewhere
here's a person with whom you don't have
any interactions whatsoever
how much money you want for yourself how
much money do you want for this other
person the original version is just sort
of one to one
any dollar that you give is given
directly to this other person
there's different versions where
essentially any dollar is converted
where essentially the exchange rate is
varied
where it's cheaper more expensive if you
give a dollar the other person gets two
dollars or 50 cents
or uh the like okay so that's the
dictator game
what's the ultimatum game it's sort of
like a bargaining game if you want it
sort of very very simple
um a game theory if you want we can use
that
which is essentially used again by
exponential economists what they do is
like there's two
players again there's a proposer or the
sender that
gives again like some divisible pie
think of this is like ten dollars of the
like often it's money
and then you say a portion of x uh is
giving them to the responder
the responder then has the chance to
either accept
or reject if the uh responder accepts
then the division is just implemented
if the responder uh rejects then
essentially
both players get nothing okay
and why is it a game now well it's
because like essentially the uh
the proposer needs to sort of take into
account what the other person is going
to do
and have some beliefs over that and
anticipating that then sort of make
their choice of like how much money
would you like to give
finally there's the trust game which is
in fact very similar to the ultimatum
game
except for that the amount sent by the
sender is tripled
before the decider the cider is supposed
to say
before they decide how much to to return
or the the the
the recipient decides how much return if
anything so uh
now essentially it's like a high return
opportunity to
uh uh give money essentially in a
situation of high trust
um in particular in this communication
if i'm playing with somebody i would
tell that person yes give me all of the
money and if you are nice to me that
money is tripled and i give you half of
it back or the like
so both of us are better off right if
there's lots of trust between us
that's actually implementable and a
sense of like i'm telling you uh give me
that money you give me that money and
then i'm actually returning that money
but of course if there's no trust and
that's where the game uh name comes from
trust game if there's no trust i'm gonna
tell you give me a bunch of money
you might actually do that and then i'll
just keep it all for myself
or you might not even believe me in the
first place you might just say yeah you
know
i'd love to but i don't trust you frank
i give you nothing
and then essentially nothing is tripled
right and that sort of
meant to then measure some form of trust
in society or people that people have
uh with each other we're going to go
back to that and trying to see
what does that actually measure in um in
the real world so just sort of having
said that those are the three things you
saw
and then there's different versions of
these games that could be sort of like
you can vary the privacy
uh are these games private versus public
is it anonymous do you know who the
other person is versus not
is there communication can you sort of
talk to this other person or not
and you know is there uh what are the
stakes i'll be talking about like
uh hypothetical choices are we talking
about money high stakes with money are
we talking about uh other goods like
apples or
uh chocolate any questions so far
we will get back to this the actual
evidence but as soon as we make sure
that these games are
clear to everyone that's sort of what
happened last time
okay now
backing up a little bit now then the
question is like what is in fact um
uh uh social preferences and so
most economic analysis and and in some
ways assumes away
um uh social preferences and sort of
assume self-interest very narrowly
defined
and so that means that the people
essentially only care about their own
interests and their own outcomes and
then the market is sort of taking care
of the rest and this is sort of at the
heart of what adam smith
originally was sort of saying i think in
the wealth of nations which is like it's
not from the benevolence of the butcher
the brewer the baker that we expect our
dinner but from their regard for their
own interest
we address ourselves not to the humanity
but to their self-love and never talk to
them
of our necessity but of their advantage
that is to say
that when everybody is very selfish and
cares about themselves
just comparative advantage and the
ability to trade with each other
will make sure that other people do
useful things for us
right so you can sort of do the work you
do make some money and then go to the
bakery and the baker will give you some
bread for someone to exchange for some
money
not because the baker likes you or wants
to be friends with you or the like but
because you pay them
and it's in their interest to give you
good bread because you're going to pay
them and then come back perhaps and buy
more bread in the future
so that's sort of a pretty reasonable
assumption and saying people are doing
useful things for each other
as part of market transaction and that's
what a lot of economics has assumed and
done
for a long time now
that is not a bad assumption at all in a
sense of like
it's actually pretty realistic in
various ways and sort of thinking about
humans
the question is not necessarily
whether there are some instances of
whether people care about others
the question that we're gonna ask is
like well what do we miss by
um ignoring social preferences and so
it's pretty clear that there are some
that preferences depart from pure
self-interest in non-trivial ways and
the question we're going to ask is like
are there some concrete settings where
we really care about this and
sort of say well we should model things
differently and if we do that we can
understand certain phenomena
better so the goal is here to understand
how common and important these
departures are and what their nature is
like how can we best
model these and here's sort of a
a nice example of of perhaps how
one might want to think about social
preferences and how perhaps people think
about
social preferences so this is a picture
i don't know how well you can see this
um
from uh taken in hawaii which is um
a sort of a box where banana bread is
being sold it's freely available to
everybody so you can just take it
i think there's some price tag somewhere
there's also like a lockbox
next to it on the left of the picture
where you can deposit payments
so the banana bread costs some money you
can deposit your payments
there's nobody that enforces it um but
the lock book is such that it's actually
locked in a sense you can't take away um
uh uh the box
so when you see that picture what do you
what perception of like social
preferences or humanity does that
reflect
how do we think about these kinds of
this picture
yes
right so one assumption to some degree
is like well people seem pretty nice
in general it seems like in a sense of
like we allow them to just take the
banana bread and run away and
you know not put in every anything we
sort of ask them nicely
it costs like a dollar or five dollars
or whatever please put in the money
it seems like the conception to some
degree is like people are going to be
nice and just
do that is that all or is that something
else yes
maybe there's an expectation not that
like everyone
would do the right thing but that like
the
sort of loss from people um from some
people who would just take the bread and
run will be
um maybe like less than for example like
the cost of labor
right exactly so there's some uh the
expectation
to be more precise is like not
everybody's going to be nice but on
average most people are going to be
pretty
pretty pretty nice or adhering to this
normal rule that like you should pay
some money and some people might run but
as you say it might not be worth sort of
standing there in the heat
all day to sort of make uh make up for
for for that exactly and then what else
uh is there yes
right there's a lock right so it's like
and sometimes you sort of think that
uh on the one hand the assumption is
like most people are going to be pretty
nice
but if we allow them to sort of run away
with all the money money at least
there's some people
who if allowed would not be uh
nice at all in fact they would take away
the money and not only not pay for the
banana bread but also take away uh
the lockbox so that's exactly
what i was written uh whatever i've
written down here which is to say people
in general are nice enough
most probably people will probably pay
for the banana bread so it's not worth
sort of standing around and sort of like
making sure ensuring that
but people also can be selfish at least
some people will be quite selfish
so if a lot of cash were easy to take
someone at least would take it
notice that's not an assumption about
like everybody or even the majority it's
just to say there's a fraction of people
who
if given the opportunity uh uh might
take away
um our money and and run from it
so that's actually a pretty good sort of
perspective um for for thinking about
social preferences
which is to say that self-interest is
probably like a major driver of behavior
in many economic contexts
in some situations self-interest is not
the main motive in some sense again like
we don't need to necessarily uh enforce
this for everybody people will be quite
quite nice but even
you know they will be sort of some
seemingly small departures from pure
self-interest can dramatically influence
economic outcomes that is to say if we
couldn't lock
um uh the the box if we were in table if
you were not doing that
somebody would sort of take away um uh
this box and now we couldn't offer
banana bread to anybody and the whole
transaction would sort of go down
but differently like if we had sort of
like things like
a theft a robbery and so on if there's
some people who are really mean and sort
of like essentially take away all of our
money
now we can't do any transaction i can't
have a shock shop trying
trying to sell stuff to people uh this
is sort of
uh the example so sort of positive and
negative uh
small things can actually make huge
differences for others
this is like helping a stranger with
directions or helping a stranger who
wants to go to the hospital and
that can make huge differences in their
lives even if the they are calling an
ambulance for somebody that can make
huge differences in people's lives even
though if the action from your side is
actually relatively small
helping a fellow student with computer
trouble or other issues that they may
have helping somebody who is sad on a
given day
feel better about themselves in fact as
you might know it's the uh
random acts of kindness week this week
so doing random acts of kindness
might actually make a huge difference in
people's lives in fact the
the problem set will will ask you to do
some of that in fact
washing your hands is sort of
particularly pertinent right now
again you might sort of think you're
doing that to protect yourself and
surely you are
but in fact it's also uh there's also a
huge externality potentially that like
by protecting yourself you protect
others um for potentially getting sick
and that could make a huge difference uh
in people's lives
any questions on this
okay so now we're getting back to the
ultimatum game i'm going to ask the
question about like
how people actually behaving in real
situations
how did people behave in general and
perhaps what does game theory say how
people should behave
uh how are people behaving in reality
and how does that compare to how you
guys behaved
here in class so again the ultimatum
game
you should be familiar with there's a
proposal responder
proposer proposes some split of the the
pie
responder can accept or um reject now
what does game theory predict
uh what people should do like in the
absence of social preferences
yes
right if you're the recipient you care
only about your own output or
you know your own outcomes even if i
offer you one cent or like five cents or
whatever whatever is worth the
transaction costs
you're going to accept everything so if
i'm playing with you i'm going to
anticipate i know that like you will
accept essentially any offer that's
uh positive uh even like xero you might
even accept because it's sort of like
what do you care
uh but you know strictly um you strictly
prefer
a positive offer over a new offer so you
can accept that
and then uh i will uh if i'm playing
with you anticipating that i will just
give you essentially the lowest possible
amount
uh and that'll be the outcomes right
so here it is the prediction is very
clear
the responder cares only this is again
game theory but games
theory in the absence of social
preferences okay should be more precise
so um the responder cares only about
money so
she will accept any x that's smaller
than zero any amount that's given
because that's better than not having
any money the proposer
will understand that will only care
about
money as well so offers as little as
possible right the proposal doesn't care
about what the risk how the recipient is
doing
so therefore the proposal will just uh
offer as little as possible to maximize
their own
um um their own uh
payout and then in equilibrium they will
essentially be the zero
smallest possible offer will be made and
that offer will be
accepted so there will be no rejections
either because essentially there's no
reason to reject
and they will also not be large offer no
large offers so the like because there's
no reason to give more than minimal
amounts um okay so then what are typical
results in the ultimatum game what do
people actually find
well so most people offer between 40 and
50 percent of the pie
such offers are mostly accepted the
acceptance rate is increasing in the
offer which is to say if you offer like
10 percent
you have a pretty good chance of being
rejected if you offer like 30 40 50
you're much more likely to be accepted
and you offer like 70 80
almost surely um you'll be accepted and
on offers below 20
are mostly rejected why is that or
what's what's what's the reason for that
presumably
yes
[Music]
right and why why are you sort of uh
upset if somebody offers you 10 percent
does it show the disrespect it's
something about like
um fairness or disrespect or you know
it's just not a nice thing to do
and now you'd rather sort of like not
have any money or like not take
one dollar whatever they offer to you
you rather reject that so you're willing
to give up a dollar
to uh essentially get back at the other
person
yeah it could also be that like um for
some people like the thought of
like um settling for such small amounts
of money and like
embarrassing or like um it feels like
it's like the meaning of
them yeah so it's one of this is i mean
some of it is
yeah exactly i think the meaning or just
feels like so
one way to put this is like you have
inequality aversion in some ways now in
the sense of like you just
don't want to be the person who has one
dollar when the other person has nine or
you won't have 10 cents when the other
has like 9.90
so you really don't like uh uh
inequality in some ways
there are some versions of this game so
the computer sort of
allocates these choices and then you can
look at our people rejecting those
offers as well and they tend to not do
that
which sort of suggests that it's really
coming from some sense of
uh not people don't care so much about
the outcome per se that care about the
fairness or the sort of intention of the
other person
but you're right there's sort of other
potential considerations at play
now what do things look like in our
class in fact this looks quite similar
to
what people do in general i know you're
very special but
when it comes to the ultimatum game
you're actually pretty ordinary
so what you see is essentially most
people offer 40 50
some people offer somewhat more you sort
of see in
you can't see this that well you see it
in red or the rejections the rejections
tend to be on the left side uh in
particular when offer when people offer
like uh between
uh one and ten percent uh there seems to
be around some rejections of fifty
percent or maybe it's just below fifty
percent
but usually if you look at like
essentially um uh about fifty percent or
forty fifty sixty percent people tend to
um uh not reject
um any offers any questions on that
yeah can you also do that people like
participating in future games
maybe not like sending a signal like
there's any similar
yes that's a great question so i kind of
like all of what i was doing and i
should
emphasize this a bit more the way i
implemented some of these games in class
like some experimental economists would
get a heart attack
in terms of like how sloppy that was in
the sense of like
a lot of these games usually when i show
you these results
these are usually very careful games
where essentially usually it's anonymous
usually it's a one-shot game usually
it's very clear that it's a one-shot
game
you will just never see that person
you'll never even interact with that
person it'll be
um clear whether it's public versus
private and so on
so usually in those games things are
extremely clear there's no
strategic interactions and so on all of
these things are essentially shut down
and then they can look at like you
randomly vary some of these
characteristics and look at deviations
of that
um so you're right in our game in fact
you know you might sort of think that
let's just be nice now
in part because the other person maybe i
played with that person again and i
wasn't really very precise about that
either i think
actually they're all like randomly
allocated so in fact
that was not a consideration but it
wasn't entirely clear or like for
example
some people were selected and it
happened to be that it was 50 50
selection that may have affected others
in class and so on
so a lot of these things were like
fairly sloppy in terms of like the
actual implementation
in the real games that would be all sort
of shut down and done um
much more carefully were some other
questions i think
okay
i think this is uh these all i looked at
all of these um the ultimatum games all
looked very
similar so this is um i think for
this is the money one um uh but even for
others it looked fairly similar i'll
show you some variation in the
uh dictator game in a second uh where we
have sort of like
do the stakes matter um uh does it
matter whether it's private private
versus public does it matter whether
it's chocolate or
money and perhaps why might it matter
but we'll get back to that in a second
turns out it does matter um i'll say a
little bit about that in a second
is
right so so that's a good point so you
were saying earlier maybe some people
have some issues about like
inequity or like inequality across
people
so that were the only explanation then
you would see rejections not only at
like
if i give you one dollar and i keep nine
but also if they give you nine dollar
um and i keep one so so that means like
there's something else i think the
fairness
people don't object to inequality if
i sort of say okay i'll give you a lot
and you have more than i do people don't
object to that people object to um if i
keep a lot and give you very little
presumably because i'm selfish and i'm
sort of uh not nice to you
so that's kind of the sense of fairness
so it's a fairness that goes beyond the
outcomes so we're going to talk about
this for a bit which is to say you could
just look at the outcomes and say how
much is the inequality of outcomes and i
care about that
but that doesn't seem to be the case
what seems to be rather the case is that
people care about intentions
one way or the other it's like what was
i thinking or was i
sort of a mean person when i was doing
this and
if you get the sense that i was not very
nice you might reject
uh almost like regardless of what the
outcome will be eventually
and of course you will reject less if uh
it's more costly for you to do so
but perhaps it's also the case if i do
like 70 30
you might say well that's maybe not
that's maybe not nice but it's also not
that unfair um either
okay
all right so now one thing you can ask
is like
um how do these games look like um
across uh
countries and as i said um um this game
has been extensively played it's like a
game that like lots and lots of people
have played in all sorts of situations
um and sort of the patterns are
remarkably
um stable across countries and this is
also a case like every time i play this
in class
these these uh patterns look exactly the
same so whether people are playing in
pittsburgh and ljubljana and
yogyakarta tokyo play also essentially
the same way
and even like increasing people's stakes
for enter like several months pay by
running essentially the experiment often
in in
and with poorer populations where you
can pay essentially
like people like days or weeks or even
like a month pay
people seem uh to pay play
very similar um across places why is
that it seems to be like somehow
rejecting becomes a lot more costly when
i offer you like a day's wage or the
like
but why do you think it looks like
fairly similar as well why do people
still reject
yes
exactly so it's exactly as you say
there's two things that going on on the
one hand
rejection becomes really expensive to me
so like you know if there's like a
a month's wage and you give me 10 of
that and keep 90
of that you know uh rejecting like
10 of like a month's wage that's like
three four days or whatever that's
really costly for me to do
however um it's also really mean of you
to sort of do that and i can really
screw you over now by sort of rejecting
um
uh uh that offer so those things
essentially
seem to be more or less can they go into
opposite directions empirically it seems
to be that sort of
cancels to each other out that's exactly
right
so now there's a very interesting
paper then that does this um ultimatum
game and hunter gathers
together our societies and asks the
question about like
well while sort of it seems to be that
people behave fairly similar um in these
games and sort of industrialized
societies whether they're sort of
relatively rich or not people seem to
behave very similarly
but perhaps if you look at
hunter-gatherer society that are quite
different in various ways perhaps there
we can look at interesting differences
across places and so
um on the one hand we see the lots of
uniformity of play like in lots of
places people seem to
um behave very similarly but you know
there's some important differences and
perhaps
uh uh what this sort of line of research
is doing call it
it's often called like cultural
economics or yeah cultural economics
just try to see
what is the role of culture and the sort
of nathan nunn and other people at
harvard
are doing this in particular sort of
inspired by uh joe hendrick who is sort
of the leader of that
um is trying to look at like what is the
role of culture and shaping people's um
preferences and so one thing they had
done and at the time is they looked at
um 15 different hunter-gatherer
societies you can see them here on the
map some of the
in south america sorry
somewhere in south america some are in
um in africa
and some are in uh uh asia
oceania um and so um you could look at
sort of these different societies
and by looking at sort of the way they
are
living and producing you can sort of try
to think about potential predictions
of how they might behave in social
preferences uh behavior
so one and there's two examples here
that we have one
is um the society
that you can see here the maki ganga
which are
i guess in which countries
in peru who in peru
and latin america you can see them they
essentially are independent families
they do a lot of cash cropping
um their way of living appears to be
slash and berm agriculture gathering
food fishing and hunting
so it's overall and you correct me if
that's wrong it seems to be fairly sort
of individualistic in the sense of like
the way people produce essentially they
live and individualistically
they are not really relying a lot of
cooperation in the way they produce
um uh uh their food or their uh their
living
in contrast um the la maleras in
indonesia these are whale hunters
essentially when you try to
hunt a whale i don't quite know imagine
at least
it requires lots of cooperation in the
sense of like people
sort of have to work together by nature
of like
essentially um finding food or or
hunting these whales
and so they on a daily basis are really
relying on corporation and so now
this line of research by hendrik and
others is trying to sort of see
can we by looking at people's
way of living and way of producing on
any different life is that predictive of
people's behavior in
ultimatum uh games and what you see is
um uh the following i'll just show you
sort of what what results are
so the um um society and and peru these
and the slashing
and burn uh horizontal culturalists seem
to have little concerns for others
outside of the family
or for social status what you see
essentially is relatively
low offers most of these offers are
um uh uh being accepted there's
essentially very low
um rejection rates um and that seems to
be essentially um
and the rejections of like um amounts
that are below 20
is only like one out of ten so it seems
to be the case
uh this society that looks like a lot
more individualistic
is in fact much closer to perhaps the
assumption of sort of the neoclassical
assumptions of no social preferences
mattering in the sense of like
they seem to be um in the way at least
they play these
the ultimatum game they seem to be happy
to offer low amounts
and they seem to also be not upset or or
annoyed or getting back to others who
offer them low amounts
in contrast if you look at the
lamalera's the the whale hunting culture
based on strong and meticulously
detailed corporation
what you see is um the mean offer is
like um
57 or the the mode is 50 percent
there are quite a few rejections in
particular rejections of
um small amounts and that's to say like
there is really sort of an expectations
of people
cooperating and if you don't cooperate
if you are not playing by those kinds of
rules
people are being punished accordingly
and there are some others there's sort
of another
culture of the um the uh
which is a culture where gift giving is
an avenue to status and gives the right
to ask for reciprocity at any time
so that's the thing that you often see
in india as well that people
tend to reject offers that are
very large in part because i think
that's sort of inappropriate i think
that's just a weird thing to do in a
sense of like
offer you like 50 or 60 percent they
just think like if i
accept this offer now i'll owe you
something and have to give you um
uh uh stuff back you are nodding
yes yes so that's that's in uh in india
as well to some degree as far as
yeah any comments on this yeah um
that's a great question i think it may
not have been i need to check
um i think so there's some question on
like how closely in some sense to the
so in any so these are sort of 15
societies so in some sense
like these are not sort of strictly
speaking statistical tests of like
um does culture cause this behavior
because you only have essentially 15
observations of kind of certain ways
people behave
um so in some sense the mapping between
the description of what i was telling
you which surely was like inaccurate in
terms of how things how people
really live in those societies and like
their behavior is more like sort of a
descriptive mapping
so in some ways it could be that even if
it were um anonymous people behave in
certain ways
that reflects a culture of um a
cooperation and sort of to say
it's just inappropriate reflect
essentially when they say it's uh
somebody gives you a large amount or a
large gift you're not supposed to accept
it
you might sort of not accept it even in
an anonymous game because you just think
that's you feel bad about it
afterwards because you can't reciprocate
reciprocate
if that makes sense but i have to look
it up um what the
specific details were the paper is also
in this very short paper
so it's also in the course website if
you issue in a look
any other comments are you from peru
do you know about the society is that is
that remotely accurate what i was saying
okay well you you can uh look into this
and report back
um uh okay but anyway it's a very sort
of interesting
um application of the ultimatum game
because it sort of essentially tries to
say
we're trying to look at how do people uh
relate in the real world
and sort of looking at these different
societies gives you some sense of like
it does seem to capture something um in
the real world of how people
are in fact um behaving
okay so now um we can sort of think
about like
um what's going on in ultimatum games
and we talked about this a little bit
but i want to be a little bit more
precise it's like
why do responders reject low offers
what's what's going on here
what are people doing
yes yes and so despite this
um so what exactly are you objecting to
uh asked this before but let me let me
ask again so if
i think like a lot of you will things
it if you think it's unfair so much so
that you would rather that they get
nothing like that you will see nothing
that you need to take this pity off
right so there's two things let me um
put them out here there's two things
here you're talking about the second
thing i think which is sort of the
fairness part so one is about like a
procedural thing which is to say
i do not i object to like the procedure
i upset object to
you not treating me nicely or fairly i'm
just mad at you for doing that therefore
i reject hypothesis number one is this
is what we were talking about earlier
which is to say
i just dislike being behind you you
offer me you you keep six
i have four i just don't like being
having less than somebody
else and i might reject that as well
can we disentangle those those
explanations
from dictator game data
yes
right so from the data that i just
showed you are from the pure sort of the
simple dictator game
it's very hard to disentangle these
because it's just it looks the same
but what you're saying now is we can
have different sort of versions of that
where you could you know have either the
computer implemented or you could choose
for other people
and then um and so on i think this is
what you were saying
and then from that you could sort of say
well if you're also rejecting
uh that then perhaps it's not about the
procedure
per se if the computer chose six and
four and you
reject it anyway then probably has to do
it's not to do with fairness because the
computer was perhaps just randomizing
but it's rather to do with like i don't
like to have
less than somebody else in the same game
right
um
i see yes i see i see so you can yes you
can do that
there's a bit of an issue a little bit
like um another version of that would be
just i don't like
uh inequality but i just might like want
to
i just really like five five or 50 50
outcomes
they already think we can look at what
you were saying earlier which is to say
i could see if there's a third party
that looks at like
um somebody choosing 60 for themselves
and 40 for somebody else
versus somebody choosing 40 versus for
themselves and 60 for somebody else
if you really just like inequality you
would just reject both of those things
and if you sort of um uh instead
think this is like you just like
inequality if the person
um only does that for themselves uh in
some selfish way
you would only reject the 60 40 but not
the 40 60.
great
right so um the answer is no we cannot
distinguish these motives based on the
ultimatum game so we need some
additional evidence to do that
uh we're going to do that mostly next
time we're going to try to make some
progress
towards that now if you now think about
the proposer's motive if a proposer
gives like a large or a small amount
what can we learn from that or why is it
difficult to figure out what the
proposer is doing
if you see somebody gives a large amount
of money what do we learn from that
yeah um it could be that they're just
being optimistic
or they it could be that they have
certain beliefs about
what the
exactly so it could be that i'm just
trying to be nice i'm trying to be
friendly i care about you i offer you 50
50.
um because i want you to have half or it
could be that i just actually don't care
about you at all i just think like if i
offer you only 30 or 20 or whatever
there's a good chance that you might
reject it
therefore i just optimize over my edges
essentially if i
so it depends on my beliefs about what
the rejection rates are
and if the beliefs are that above below
30 40
people's rejection rates are positive
and sort of higher
i might essentially just maximize
depending on my wrist preferences or
whatever suppose i'm just neutral i
might just maximize expected
uh payout i might be that essentially 40
or 50
is just the optimal optimal uh the
solution to that maximization problem
and i just don't care about uh you
whatsoever so from looking at this
behavior essentially
from looking at like an ultimatum game
and looking at a proposer
offering large amounts of positive
amounts we can learn nothing about their
or it's very hard to learn anything
about their social preferences
because essentially their strategic
motives potentially
involved as well is that clear or any
questions
so what do we need to do then well now
we need to sort of have some
some some uh other evidence
so we talked about this already when you
think about sort of social preferences
you can think about like three broad
categories of preferences and we're
gonna
talk about this a lot more so one is
distributional preferences
this is to say that um you care about
like
outcomes you care about how much each
person gets right that's to say we can
sort of represent this to like
i put some weight on my utility on my
outcomes i put some weight on your
outcomes
and then depending on what that weight
is i'm going to decide
about how to distribute outcomes these
are sort of distributional preferences
then there are things like we want to
call like face saving concerns
which is people don't want to
look bad in front of others you can also
think about this like social image which
is to say
i want to look like an i'm a nice guy so
like in particular if i'm in public
making certain choices if i'm being
observed
i'm going to behave very in a very
friendly way
if i could sort of secretly be mean i
would do that
but as long as my social image is at
stake i might look um
like a nice person we're going to talk
about some experimental evidence looking
at that
and then there's sort of some um which
we're going to call intentions-based
preferences these are things like
reciprocity procedural justice
and sort of other facets of social
preferences
broadly speaking you can think of this
as like fairness which is to say it's
like
people don't care about like the
outcomes per se they care about
essentially the process
in which um uh uh the outcomes were
generated
right so they might be perfectly happy
with like one person getting a lot and
another person getting nothing
as long as the computer randomized the
next ante the probability of getting
money was the same for everybody
so that would be somebody who said uh
these would be intention-based
preferences where people sort of say
this is procedural justice this is a
fair thing to do
um and people
um are motivated um uh by that or that's
essentially uh
they might reciprocate in cases when
they think things are unfair
they might not do so in case they think
things are
fairly generated even if things are in
equal exposed
okay so now um we're gonna talk about
all three of those so let's start with
distributional preferences um this is
sort of again the simplest kinds of
social preferences
this is very much like a natural
extension of how
economists think about the world this is
going back to gary becker i think in the
60s
where essentially instead of saying like
there's a utility function that just has
my own
outcomes as of my own consumption as an
argument instead i have a utility
function that has my own utility how
much i get
and the function of that plus how much
does the other person get
and the weight on that other person and
so um uh again we sort of look at like
uh the person cares not about only how
much they
get but also the other there's two
versions of that and this is what you're
saying earlier they're sort of
interested distributional preferences
and disinterested distributional
preferences
the interesting interested one is
essentially the version is like
where i'm involved and i get a certain
outcome and there's another person
involved
and i put some weight on that other
person so it's about me versus another
person and how do
these resources are being divided
could be also multiple pers people of
course and then there's the
disinterested part which is to say
kind of like how do i want resources to
be divided um
across others this is kind of questions
like you know how do we want society to
look like how do we how do people feel
about inequality and the like
um or like what public goods how much
should the government engage in uh
redistribution and so on these
would be often uh to some degree of
course it's interested because
people have to pay taxes or or receive
sort of
benefits from the government but often
it's like you can ask questions people
have opinions about
you know suppose you live in the us you
could have opinions about how should
europe's tax system look like
what is fair and what is unfair those
would be essentially disinterested
distributional
preferences
any questions on on that so we're going
to start with this and see
how far can we get distributional
preferences what kinds of things can be
explained
and then we're going to move towards
like saving phase or like social image
type of concerns so the dictator game
already explained to you
what it looks like so
here's usually um here's what the
dictator game
looked like in class with no stakes this
is very typical to how people behave
in the real world um what do we see here
what are what are sort of um
patterns of behaviors
this is no mistake so this is sort of
hypothetical questions here
exactly and this is what a very typical
um uh
again in many situations there's a group
of people often like 30
40 of people who just essentially just
keeps the money
um there's a group of people that thinks
like 50 50 is like sort of the right
thing to do
that's often also something like thirty
percent of people and then there's
people like often in between
often between zero and fifty and there's
some people who
who who tend to give a lot uh uh that's
often like a minority of
people now one what can we infer from
those choices what can we infer from
people who choose zero
yes
[Music]
and uh is do we have any
objections to that or like what other
interpretation could we have
yes
yeah exactly so in the case of money um
you could sort of keep the money you
could say
i'm choosing the ten dollars
and instead i'm giving it to somebody
who is in higher need who has higher
marginal value of this
this money uh that could be um
you know you could give it to charity or
give it to somebody on the
on the street or any other person you
think is in need so that person who
looks like they're fairly selfish
might in fact be quite generous in the
sense of like give it to
the the money to others um that's a
common issue with a lot of these games
is essentially there's
often like an outside option in the
sense of like we can look at these games
as if this is the only game that's the
only thing that's happening in the world
and nothing else
and look at sort of try to explain
behavior through that but
often the issue is like there's other
things that happen in the world
so when i think about like am i behind
or um do i get more money versus
somebody else
you know when you play with somebody who
is a lot richer a lot poorer than you
are
in fact you know giving them ten dollars
versus not or five dollars or not will
not change that fact that you're a lot
richer than they are
so perhaps you should give a lot more a
lot less money and so on
so in anything that we're sort of
assuming we look at this in the lens
through the lens of like there's only
this game that happens and nothing else
it turns out that's actually a pretty
good approximation people sort of what
we call it narrowly frame they look at
essentially this game as if this is like
completely separate from anything else
in
in in the world so people tend to not
integrate these games with like the rest
of life or the rest of utilities so
expected utilities would say
you should integrate this game with
everything else that happens in life
so you should not look at like six
versus four i'm earning more than
somebody else
you should look at like what is my
income overall a lifetime income what is
your lifetime income or the expected
lifetime
time income of somebody else in the
experiment and depending on that you
should give money or not
or differently you might say well should
i give money to somebody else in class
well perhaps not because most people in
class will um
will eventually make a lot of money um
once they graduate
and uh instead let's just fuse that
money and sort of give it
uh to somebody else who has higher need
of that
okay so here's no stakes it turns out
when you look at stakes
not much happens so this is answers if
you look at this there's no stakes
here's like stakes answers look in fact
very similar there's not much of a
difference
even when you have like higher stakes i
think just like twenty dollars and the
like people
seem to behave very similarly so it
seems to be like in fact
asking hypothetical questions and this
is how some of these games started
just asking hypothetically what how
would what would you do if somebody gave
you ten dollars and so on
turns out you actually get pretty good
answers for how people
behave in reality that's true for this
class but it's also true in actual
experiments and actual experiments if
you just ask people like what would you
do
and then when you actually implement it
with the same people or with other
people you get actually pretty similar
patterns
across people now we do find that like
we
had a version of that that was
essentially in private which is to say
um you know you did not have to reveal
if selected to the entire class
essentially what you chose but only to
the other person
notice that that's not really private in
the sense of like you still have to sort
of tell the other person how it shows 10
and you get zero
so that's not very nice there's other
versions that would be in private would
just be like
the other person might never find out or
the other person might at least never
find out that it was you who chose 10
and they got zero right and so but what
we do see if you look at sort of this is
like now um i think this is like with
monetary six this is when
ten dollars this is when with ten
dollars in private and you do see for
example that
when you look at the fraction who gives
essentially a hundred percent that
fraction tends to uh uh go down
so do it looks like people are um
somewhat less nice and private
we're going to get back to that um again
in the sense of like trying to see when
we look at the question of like are
people really nice when they
um give money and so on we're going to
look at sort of cleaner versions of that
where people have the
ability to essentially hide in some ways
that they're not nice
how might one do that how could you what
kind of game would you design to to to
hide the fact that the person is not
nice
um yes recipient is only like
given the money and not for like what
percentage of the original ones
right so one version of that would be
like the recipient just doesn't even
know what the game is
they just get some money and here's
here's some money for whatever reason
you were just given it because you're in
the experiment and
so you could just essentially hide the
entire uh game from the recipient
what's another thing you could do where
you don't hide the entire game but sort
of say still there's a game but what
other ways could you
in what other ways could you hide the
fact that people are not nice
like what mechanisms could you implement
yeah um
exactly and that's exactly i'm going to
show you that i think on wednesday
that's exactly what people have done
where you say with 50 chance there's a
robot who's like not very nice or like
very nice or whatever
some chance the robot is really mean
with some chance the robot is really
nice
and now we can look at like so with 50
so the robot decides with 50
chance you decide and the recipient will
never know whether it was a robot versus
uh you right and so now you can
essentially hide behind the robot you
can say well
i really wanted to give you lots but
sorry the robot was really mean
uh too bad and the other person will
never
find out and it turns out when you do
that kind of game
people tend to be a lot less nice
than when there's no robot okay
so then um we have um
a chocolate looks like people are giving
someone more when it comes to chocolate
they tend to give a lot more when
when it comes to apples um
so now why is that why does that matter
yes
if you model like um
your utility plus like the other
principles you know
multiplier it could be that like people
have weight
um people's marginal utility and
chocolate apples
decline way more yes it turns out like
getting the fifth or sixth or seventh
apple of the day
uh uh might be not as enjoyable as like
the first or second
um um so you know exactly so like well
it's pretty reasonable to think that the
marginal utility of money is linear for
small
um small amounts but we give you one
dollar two three or four or five
in some sense that's that's that
shouldn't be very concave we discussed
that at length
for apples uh the perishable there's
only so many apples you can eat on a
given day
so really what we should look at is like
what's the utility of apples and if the
marginal utility of apples is decreasing
uh that might matter quite a bit
okay so um
maybe let me sort of summarize a little
bit like what did we learn in those
kinds of games
so first um is uh people look
um fairly generous in dictator games
even when the game is
um largely private we're going to sort
of challenge that assumption a little
bit more
exactly as you suggested with sort of
other ways in which either
people can be more private they can just
hide the game entirely
or when they perhaps can hide behind a
machine or a computer or in other
ways or when they perhaps can opt out of
the game in certain
ways people generally seem to give
something like
30 of the total that's quite common 20
to 30 percent is quite
common overall it doesn't seem to matter
that much whether there's hypothetical
versus actual choices
the size of the steaks also seem not to
matter
that much we seem to see somewhat
different behaviors of chocolates and
apples
there's also some people who told me
that there's lactose intolerant and so
on so essentially saying like
their marginal utility of chocolate is
quite low so it's much easier it's much
less costly to give to somebody else
or put differently it's actually
efficient potentially because the
marginal utility of chocolate is much
higher for that other person
than it is for you of course there's a
problem now again that you could just
choose the chocolates for yourself and
then just give it to your friends
so you look kind of like quite selfish
but in fact you might not be
so anyway but sort of the what really
matters here and this is sort of
perhaps in some sense when i when we
talk about sort of apples and chocolates
that's a little bit silly
but when you think about a dictator game
where you play with somebody in kenya
who's whose uh income or life dying
income is like orders of magnitude is
lower than yours
then it matters actually quite a bit
what's the marginal uh utility of the
ten dollars that you could keep for
yourself versus for that person for that
person that's a lot of money
for you um a lot less and so you might
be
more generous when playing with a person
whose marginal utility of of money
or consumption is a lot higher um
this is what i was mentioning as well
it's like the you want to think about
kind of like what is the outside option
so some people might give low amount and
decide to give the money or the
the apples or whatever to somebody else
those people will look selfish in
dictator games well in fact they're
quite
generous that's a problem with these
games that are hard to
hard to deal with we're not going to be
able to sort of
deal with that overall they can sort of
think about a little bit and sort of see
like you know can we
give people options to opt out and so on
but it'll
always be an issue it's less of an issue
than you perhaps think about it
conceptually that's a huge problem
but when we look at people's actual
behavior it looks like people really
behave as if this was the only thing in
the world
and sort of then in some ways it's quite
predictive of actual behavior in the
world even perhaps
in some ways it shouldn't um be any
other comments or things we learned
perhaps from the game or that you
observed
yeah is there a possibility for the
people that like gave zero it's just
that their
sort of like interested uh distribution
like the deal is the same as
disinterested one where they actually
think like oh the best thing for
society is for me to have ten dollars
and not the other person
so because you put a lot of weight on
yourself or
regardless if it's correct or not like
do you think that like
the way is better for society than the
other person
yeah i mean i think so you have to sort
of justify that somehow in a sense of
like
if you are very similar to the other
students then you would might sort of
think that
dividing it so depends like what you
think is the marginal utility of
money so if you think the marginal
utility of money is essentially the same
for everybody
in some sense then it doesn't matter
very much whether you keep it to
yourself versus somebody else in some
sense because
in the grand scheme of things it doesn't
look very different it could be that for
example you think for whatever reason
you just really had a bad day and you
can use the ten dollars to buy you
something nice
it could be that you think you're
relatively poor to others in
in class for whatever reason you just
don't have a lot of money right now
the marginal utility of money for you
might be really high so again
and in some sense that's like socially
efficient you would actually even if it
just
if it weren't you you would give the
money to yourself
now i think uh it is the case that when
you look at sort of these distributions
um it tends to be that 30 percent of
people sort of keep
all of that money so it tends to be that
like it's hard to believe that that sort
of
that's really i mean you'd have to look
at like how does that correlate with
other characteristics
it probably does um and we'll get back
to that in the sense of like
when we see now when people have the
chance to hide money and so on when you
see now the fraction of people who
choose ten dollars for themselves and
zero for others goes up
that in some ways compared to like when
you can't hide that it perhaps is then
identifying selfishness and so on
here when you see people keeping 10 you
can come up with lots of explanations
including the one that you mentioned
but also including the ones you keep it
for yourself and give it to your friends
and share it with them and so on
and uh we can't really infer very much
but in these sort of cleaner experiments
where you can sort of like really
say okay when you don't have the outside
option when you don't have the
chance to hide you look quite nice that
goes away when you have the chance to
hide
presumably that is because you just are
selfish
and not for other reasons okay
yes surely they
surely they have what i don't know so
surely the entire denominator is very
robust in various situations
so my guess is they were less likely to
give
i don't have like i can look it up but i
don't have like a great um
experiment that that i can tell you
about
but my sense is that like so the
question is like if you give people the
ten dollars
into their hand are they gonna like
choose differently my guess is they will
look a lot less
selfish in the experiment that you
played in some sense you are sort of
endowed with the game so in some ways
but you could do deviations of that you
could look at like here's ten dollars to
neither yours nor the other person's how
would you like to divide it
my guess is the person will be more
generous when they do that compared to
saying like
here's ten dollars i give it to you in
one dollar
bills and now you have to give me back
some people will be more likely to keep
the money
when they actually have the money in
hand when they feel like it's yours
or theirs as opposed to like they have
to divide
uh money that's not that that doesn't
really belong to any person
so my guess is that's true but i don't
that there's literally thousands of
experiments of people doing these kinds
of
variations so i'm sure that if somebody
has done this i can look up and see
whether i find that okay any other
thoughts of what we learned
so now when you now think about like how
should you model these
distributional preferences and there's a
classic paper by chinese and raven
um raven is the the guy that you know
from the calibration theorem about risk
preferences
and the way they models is very simple
they essentially um have the preferences
over outcomes
x1 and x2 think of this as like money it
could be also apples or something else
money is perhaps a better approximation
because the margin utility of money
think of this is rather constant and now
um player 2 is a dictator so
x2 is how much player 2 gets so
player 2 has a utility function u2 the
utility of
player 2 as a function of x1 this is how
much the other person gets and x2 how
much the
player 2 gets and the utility function
looks like
rho times x1 plus 1 minus rho times x2
if x2 is larger or equal than x1 that is
to say if the person is
ahead if x2 gets more than x1 and it's
sigma times x1 plus 1 minus sigma x2
if x2 is smaller equal than
x1 so what do these parameters measure
what do row and sigma measure here
well why might they be different yeah
next year
yes so um exactly what does it do how
much weight do you put on
yourself or the other person or so if
you were
right so in the extreme case i guess if
you are and then in one case i guess if
you choose uh
if this is zero then essentially you're
back in the new classical case of like
not caring about others at all
right so for if you choose like row
sigma equals zero
then it's just like how much do you get
you should give zero and you should
accept any offer
right and now if um as rho and sigma
goes up
uh 0.5 or whatever like you care give
more weight on the other person
so 0.5 for example is the case where you
care equally about
the other person and yourself
right because the weights are then the
same now why might row and sigma be
different
yes
[Music]
and why is that
[Music]
yeah exactly it's just easier that seems
to be like a very sort of intuitive
um uh feature of the world it seems to
be much easier to be generous when
you're ahead anyway
if you like very rich you might as well
give some money to the poorer person and
so on
if you are um uh poorer than the other
person
it's much harder to be generous in some
ways perhaps because you
feel like you deserve to be do they get
as much as the other person
so why would you give the other person
uh more
would you you put essentially less
weight on on that other person if you're
behind what's the case of sigma smaller
than zero
yeah exactly so if you're behind so
sigma is the case where you're behind
you're the
x2 the the player two if player two is
behind has less than uh
a player one now you might um
uh you you might get positive utility
from like
reducing player one's outcome
so you might if you're behind you'd
rather have the other person get less
and you feel better about that
because perhaps presumably because
you're then less behind
even calling constant your own um your
own outcomes okay so if you keep your
own
outcome your own payment the same
suppose you get five the other person
gets 20.
you feel better if the other person gets
15 or 10 because you're like less behind
now than the other
um person okay so you're willing to hurt
the other person
you might be even willing to pay to hurt
the other person which is kind of like
what happens in the dictator game
when the person rejects the dictator
game
any questions on that
so we have an example of rho uh sorry
sigma is smaller than one
suppose you have sigma being minus one
third
do you have to choose between zero zero
and nine one what are you gonna choose
so i just so this is what this looks
like sigma times x1 plus
1 minus sigma x2
yeah right so essentially the reason is
that essentially you
if you look at this uh this equation
here you put the minus one third
weight essentially on the other person
so you really don't like the other
person getting nine
so that's um uh uh you know be really
unhappy
about that despite the fact that like uh
you
value getting some money yourself you
have positive value in that as well it's
like
i guess four thirds times uh one but
sort of putting together that's negative
so essentially you're willing to pay and
this is i guess sort of like
one explanation potentially why people
might reject and this is i guess what i
was saying earlier
you might reject the ultimatum game
simply for distributional reasons you
might just say i don't like being behind
in this game
if i'm behind i put like negative weight
on this other person
and then i'm not rejecting it because i
feel happier if the person who is uh
uh in front of me gets less
even if that comes at the cost of me
having to
to to to pay some money now notice you
are not going to reject all
unequal offers so i think 6'4 you would
probably accept
but you will reject really uneven
offers so in some sense if i ask you
questions using the strategy method as
we did if i ask you questions about at
what threshold would you
reject an offer i can essentially if i
assume that your preferences look like
this
i can back out essentially your sigma
questions on that yep
sorry this is just a sorry it should
have been clear so this is um
this could be for um
these are preferences that are generic
for any types of games that are being
played
so this could be for you could apply
this to any game
so charnes and raven essentially what
they do is
in their paper and it's sort of a long
paper um that covers a lot of ground
but essentially what they're saying is
like here's what distributional
preferences might look like
and you can then choose different
parameters and then the question is like
what kinds of behavior now can we
explain
being the dictator game potentially you
can try to explain sort of people's
behavior
but now i'm sort of trying to apply it
to the ultimatum game or you could also
apply to the trust game and say
for what kinds of behavior what kinds of
preferences
might people do certain behavior so what
kinds of uh
behaviors can we explain um with that
um so now what's the experimental
evidence on
on row and sigma just to remind you row
is the parameter um the weight that you
put on the other person if your head
sigma is the parameter and the other
person when you're um uh behind in
in a situation so um we think that when
people are ahead most people seem to
have a positive
row so people usually tend to um win
ahead
they're willing to sacrifice some money
to increase the other person's payoff
right so this is essentially when you
think about dictator games when they
have 10
essentially think of this as being like
10-0 you're ahead
so you're willing to sacrifice let's see
some money like three or
six four even five five you like that
better you're happy to give the other
person
some amount a minority are even willing
to sacrifice money to give the other
person an equal amount of money or even
less
or even sorry or even more
when deciding to split ten dollars um uh
subjects tend to give about 20 to 25
on average in class that was actually
pretty close to 28
i think are about the monetary the 10
amount you guys gave it
something like 28 that's actually pretty
close to what people would do in uh
normal dictator games
the estimated row tends to be about
point four yeah
um how can row be estimated from the
different games
the linearity of the preferences here
shouldn't it predict that
um player two will always either give
either get zero or again fifty percent
uh no just to say i think this is just
to say you have the same margin utility
than i have so depending on
uh when i ask you like how much do you
give that essentially
that pins down uh uh your
row but if you um if like
x one is like 10 minus x2
and you want to maximize rho x1 plus 1
minus 0
times x2 and
you're maximizing that over x2 synthesis
no no but the the uh the unknown here is
the rows essentially to say for example
you choose six four that means like you
prefer six four of the seven
three and you prefer six four or five
five and those two inequalities
essentially give you a bound on
row we can talk afterwards but i'm
pretty sure that's true
uh uh yeah or yeah um
so but yeah that's essentially just
saying like essentially what you do is
like you have um since you
chose a certain option now essentially
you you'd preferred not to choose a
higher option you preferred not to
choose a lower option
when you write that down that should
give you inequalities uh as a function
of row
in this case yeah but we'll talk about
it
in in two minutes um what's the
experimental evidence of sigma
um only about 10 to 20 percent of
players have sigma strong enough to pay
a long triple amount to hurt the other
player these are people essentially who
reject offers
about 30 of people will sacrifice to
help a player ahead of them
so even if they're behind and have the
option of like can you sort of um
help the person in front of you thirty
percent of people will do that
uh if a person is behind she often
either wants to help hurt the other
person by much essentially
sort of like whatever i don't care about
this other person i don't feel like
inclined to do very much
but also not necessarily um hurting them
so um now when i sort of just preview
um what we're going to talk about next
time which is to say
it looks like people are pretty nice in
various situations it looks like in a
dictator game they give money it looks
like in the ultimatum game they give
money and so on
looks like people give money to charity
this is what we discussed earlier about
two percent of gdp
um you know people also like do a lot
bunch of volunteering or other other
sort of contributions
so to give some time about like 15 hours
per month on average when you do surveys
so it looks like people seem um fairly
generous
overall now when you think about sort of
social
recognition or social image perhaps that
picture
gets less rosy overall it seems to be
that essentially
people care a lot about what others
think of them
and not just about sort of the outcomes
per se so one example would be gifts to
organizations if you look at sort of
thresholds of like when you look at the
boston symphony orchestra and look at
the distribution of people's giving
it tends to be there's like these
thresholds where you can give a certain
amount and then you recognize and like
when you go to the boston symphony and
this booklet you can sort of see
who's like a certain donor of which
category people tend to bunch just above
the thresholds for these categories and
presumably that's because they want to
look good
that's just one example so i think the
next question we're going to ask
on wednesday is to say is social
recognition a major motivation
for giving so people seem to not only
care about what others get but what
others
think of them when they give or uh not
so in some ways that's a philosophy
philosophical discussion and saying like
are people really nice versus not
and you might say it's sort of
disappointing if they're not nice in
certain situations compared to other
the flip side of that is well if you
sort of know what kinds of situations
generate
altruistic or pro-social behavior well
if you know that then we can essentially
also create situations to
foster pro-sociality right so once we
kind of know
on under which structure or in which
kind of behavior which kind of
circumstances people
are nice well that gives us sort of some
a lever or some ways for policy saying
like well you have to design your
institutions or your organizations or
your company in certain ways
to get people to behave nice to each
other in contrast if you thought people
are either generally nice or not well
then in some sense that's
good to know but then in some sense we
can't do very much about that and that's
what we're going to talk about
next time thank you
you